[Music]
let's go
okay so e4
um let's play a
okay let's play some sort of a sicilian
i don't know which one but i want to
play a sicilian
i want to play a night or i want to play
i want to play night or
um let's play d6 night off is sort of my
childhood opening
i don't play it as much anymore and
obviously he could play anti-sicilian
yeah he does plan tyson b3
okay b3 is a legitimate move it's rare
uh but it's one of those you know
one one possible anti-sicilian
black has many good setups against b3
many good ways to meet this
but um
okay let me let me just remember what i
analyzed
okay i think i know what i want to show
you guys
so one very good setup against uh the
move b3 is well first of all
let's begin with the development of
knight c6 and then i'll show you what to
do after bishop b2 he could also go
bishop b5 that's second move bishop b2
on a basic level
okay thank you domino d on a basic level
this is a good bishop it's on a long
diagonal
if we wanted to shut this bishop down
could we do that could we shut this
bishop down
and that's what we're going to do
yeah we're gonna play the movie five now
some of you might think this move is
problematic and it has its drawbacks it
weakens the d5 square
uh quite seriously
it you know you might think it makes the
bishop bad and all of that technically
is true
but the fact that we are shutting down
his bishop as severely as we are this is
kind of called the batmanic setup
although not exactly but you can think
of it that way
is it's all worth it and as i'll show
you guys
this bishop is
going to it's going to come alive later
i believe that
how should we continue the setup we have
several ways to
uh to manage the development of the
knight of the bishop the most simple way
is to just go knight f6 and bishop b7
nothing wrong with that at all
but if we want to preserve the integrity
of the batmanic setup what we do is we
fee encounter this bishop
and get the knight over to e7
why would we go to such lengths uh to do
that because once we castle who can tell
me what plan becomes a lot easier to
achieve what active plan on the king
side
if you play the king's indian then
you'll know what i'm talking about f5 at
some point we want to be able to play a
five and tear things open on the king's
side
now you might ask well why don't we do
it immediately and then play knight f6
well it's premature you don't want to
weaken the king this early in the
opening before you've completed your
development right so
in what order shall we do things i like
fiancee the bishop first you could also
start with my g7 but fianchettoing is a
little bit more flexible because maybe
in some situations we'll want to get the
knight over to f6 now the typical 1900
move here would be to play knight t5 and
that wouldn't be bad but i'll talk about
it so bishop g7
fiance
so yeah there we go
um
i've got my experience of these types of
players i've taught good good share of
them
now
with outpost there's two things to bear
in mind
technically speaking this is an outpost
right because no pawn can chase away the
knight
but outposts can also be chased away or
traded off by your pieces and so thank
you so much just dozier with a rate of
74. chess outposts can be traded by
pieces and so particularly this is good
when you're just developing normally and
simultaneously contesting the outpost so
all you have to do here don't panic
don't go to crazy moves just knight g7
um and i'm finishing up a speed run here
guys for today we're having tons of hype
so much support today
super appreciative
and now another raid bishop b5
again don't panic and take on d5 because
after he takes d5 the knight is going to
be pinned
um
well what would be the most sort of
authoritative move let's put it this way
what would be the most authoritative
move yeah just go a6 chase away this
damn bishop if he takes on c6 we will
definitely take with a pawn and force
this knight out of d5 he goes back to e2
great get out of there
okay so let's castle
again notice that i'm not even taking
his knight we don't need to rush with
that we don't need to rush with that
move
until
we feel that the moment the opportune
moment has arrived
i feel like that opportune moment is now
he's played a very weird move c3 and he
clearly wants to play d4 and open up the
center so
i think this is the appropriate time to
take on d5 and where are we going to put
the knight afterward why is this the
moment to take on d5 where are we going
to put the knight after he takes back
we are going to put it on
e7 we're going to put it back where the
other knight was
immediately attacking the pawn on d5 and
what you guys are going to see
is that he's got to defend that pawn
and he'll probably defend it by playing
c4 there it is
and now he can no longer play d4 so
we've basically caused him to lose a
tempo
do you guys want to set a trap here now
there is a move that a lot of you should
see if particularly if you're doing your
tactics
you should see a particular idea here
um the idea is e4
e4 exposes an attack against the bishop
and attacks the knight let's calculate
it for a second
after e4
he has to play bishop takes bishop
now what additional option do we have
here
what additional option do we have here
so let's calculate method if e4 bishop
takes g7 we can take the knight on f3
that's correct
take the knight on f3
and after bishop takes f8 uh e take f
takes e2 i'm sure you've probably seen
lines like this queen takes e2 queen
takes f8 and at the end of the day
we have two pieces for a rook black is
better there undoubtedly black is better
against another gm i would have played
e4
but i want to set a trap i want to show
you guys how these traps could work
so we go rookie first we hope that he
castles we hope that he doesn't
understand what the idea is and castles
he does
um but still e4 is extremely strong in
this position i anticipated that
still e4 is extremely strong because if
he plays bishop takes g7 then we play e
takes f3 the rook is no longer hanging
so that's why rookie 8 is an interesting
move
it's a little bit of hope chess but
here's the thing folks
okay thank you for the bishop it doesn't
ruin your position and the the most
important advice that i can share in
terms of setting traps is to only do it
it's fine to set some traps you don't
have to play like a saint
but you got to make sure that it doesn't
ruin your position so what do we do now
he just messed this up completely boom
boom same diagonal bishop f5 good job
malcolm
and i
you guys know that on the speed run i
don't advocate this kind of play but
once in a while it's fine you know once
in a while sending a trap and seeing
what happens is is standard and i want
to also show you what that looks like
let's take here we're not he's going to
go knight g5 but we're not afraid of
that
okay so why are we not afraid of it
because
we have many ways to deal with this
what's the simplest way of dealing with
the threats
yes downward
i'm i'm advocating right now but please
don't take my words out of context i'm
not advocating setting traps in every
position what i'm advocating is once in
a while if you see a very juicy trap
that you feel like is easy to miss
and and it doesn't
uh clearly ruin your position if your
opponent sees through it
it's fine to do it once in a while
um
this concept that you should never set
tricks tricks are always bad
who are we kidding here i i don't
subscribe to that thought yeah knight f5
is excellent here knight f5 bringing the
knight out
exposing his knight on g5 everything
collapses the bishop is hanging this is
over
at the end of the day you're playing
chess to win games that's that's the
bottom line goal here
so
if there is a kind of a practice that
raises your percentage
and doesn't build terrible habits
but maybe isn't the way you'd play
against the gm that's okay
so bishop e5 is extremely strong here
dislodging
the queen from the knight
uh we could also have taken on e2 first
and then got bishop e5 it really doesn't
matter
why doesn't the opponent resign i have
no idea but
he's under no legal obligation to
okay knight f7
okay now as soon as you see an option to
trade queens i would take it just
straight queens don't bother yourself
with crap
don't bother yourself with various uh
shenanigans just take the knight we
could have also taken the [ __ ] it
doesn't matter i'm not gonna really
comment on this
okay now if you want to play clinically
bishop d3 is good here but let's just
take
i don't care
let's get the rook into e2
let's swing the bishop over to d4
centralizing and attacking f2
he's probably gonna go king f1
or rook d1 okay
thanks again guys for the incredible
support today i
really really appreciate it
um alternature with a hundred subs
to kyo
and um
chickafunga with 50.
that's crazy so let's quickly take a
look
um
and i'll be back later on as well
so um
yeah so this e5 move
uh shuts down the bishop because it
creates a little bit of a pawn chain
here that forces the bishop to bite on
granite
now
again a lot of you hesitate to play this
move because
it weakens the d5 square but i have the
sort of because i'm experiencing these
structures one of the things that i know
is that 95 is usually not dangerous
just putting the knight on d5 does not
automatically create threats against
your position that's what you have to
understand
so
first of all do not go here
because then you get checkmated that
would be a little sad
thank you jesus shuttle's worth three
appreciate it
um
so don't do that
i've seen people lose like that first
you would want to fianchetto the bishop
but at your leisure you can play knight
g7 and guess what
that knight is gonna get traded this
knight is not actually giving him any
kind of advantage
so what's the generalizable lesson here
outposts
um
how should i let me think about how to
formulate this
an outpost is not inherently good
um you should only fear an outpost if it
truly is eternal like you really cannot
trade anything for that piece or if it
causes some sort of active damage to
your position oh he puts a knight on d5
and it dominates over the position
outposts do not win
games
uh moves win games and an outpost needs
to be converted into some other
advantage to win nobody has ever won a
game only because of an outpost
an outpost is a positional advantage
that has to be further transformed or
combined with other advantages
for outpost and russian is for post it's
like four post
for post yeah
so it's similar
so h3 bishop g7 and here you can very
clearly see the fact that we are
essentially able to take the knight at
our leisure
so a6 why is that important because i
wanted to get rid of the pin
and i was hoping that he would take on
c6
uh because then we would take with a
pawn we would get this very nice pawn
mass even though the pawns are doubled i
still like the structure
and then what's going to be our
follow-up here with black how should
black continue in this position
not d5 so that's a mapwa that's the most
popular wrong answer
that's the most popular wrong answer
although d5 is not terrible
d5
um goes against the zen of this setup
because it reopens the bishop it gives
the bishop a purpose
and after something to the effect of ed
and rookie one
you can see how weak the e5 pawn becomes
maybe even knight e5 works i don't want
to calc i'm too lazy to calculate this
but maybe this works something like f6
f4 and even if it doesn't work you're
basically giving this bishop a purpose
again
um and i would say this over extends
black just a little bit so instead of d5
go f5 f5 is far stronger and then you
have basically two ideas either opening
up the f-file or if he allows you to do
it go king's indian style f4 g5 h5 g4
and try to overrun him with pawns this
is a super typical plan look at how
passive white's positions white has no
clear ideas here maybe c3 and t4 but
this is not terribly dangerous
i would maybe lean toward taking on e4
and playing with the pieces
but this is an excellent position either
way if they capture without ef5
yeah bishop is fine i like tanking the
pawn too
and then creating the possibility of
maybe a rook left to g6
um and we just have incredibly good pawn
center here i just like this the look of
this
but don't take with a rook here because
that's a little clunky and it blocks the
bishop so either i would say either
sorry uh either take with a bishop or
take with a pawn
um what do i think about bishop d7
instead of a6
it's fine but again
why not just
why not force the matter when you when
you want i mean why keep his bishop on
an active square i just don't see the
benefit of that and this bishop is
perfectly fine as it is i wouldn't
necessarily feel the urge to develop it
further to d7
okay so the way that he played takes
takes 97 c4 now rookie is the trap so
again if e4 instead
we've got this mass trade
and we get two pieces for a rook then
this knight can come out to d4
so black is better
but rookie 8 is a classic preparatory
move um what should he have done it's
not actually that easy to defend against
this believe it or not
because e4 is a standalone threat the
knight has no good places to go that's
the funny thing so after queen c2e4
what he should have done
is probably just like knight h2 bite the
bullet here
um
okay uh minor protocol thank you for the
prime now if he had got knight g5 here
after takes takes as a last question who
can tell me
uh how black should proceed in this
position this is a trick question guys
this is a trick question
it's not knight takes d5 that's the
thing because after knight take who can
tell me why
it's not knight takes d but this is hard
because of knight f7 this is a desperado
counter sacrifice after which the
position is unclear although black is
still better
but
remember you don't always have to do
something with a sacrifice knight f5 in
my opinion is much stronger why because
you attack the knight just the same
the knight is no good squares you have
to defend it
now get out of there
and now look at how much black dominates
here you can take on h4 and then this
knight swings over to this amazing
square d4 and this actually is an
incredible outpost because in contrast
to the knight on d5 this knight is
unassailable it's
almost impossible to trade it white's
knight is like nowhere near e2 and this
knight creates
you know actual serious threats knight
takes c2 it presses down on white's
position and it combines with the other
pieces uh you know that's the point i'm
trying to make here
you should not consider an outpost as a
standalone unit you have to look at how
the other pieces are working with it
yeah he could sack the screen that's
true
and so that's how we won the game okay
he blundered the bishop but
at the end of the day he was already in
trouble
um
so by the way guys rookie is not a
cheesy move it's the computer's third
recommendation second now
rookie it is basically the strongest
move in the position because e4 is such
a such a strong threat so like i said i
was not trying to play cheap crappy
moves it didn't ruin the position at all
e4 is a very very strong very hard
thread to deal with
um
and now it's top
now it's top rookie it is a topo
actually so
sometimes traps also correspond
with being the best move it is kind of a
trap that we're threatening to win a
piece but e4 isn't only threatening to
win a piece also this knight is nowhere
to go if that makes sense
um okay guys i gotta go i have a lesson
i have another lesson
i will try to be back for about another
hour and a half at approximately 8 15
eastern
um
i'll try to be back for an hour and a
half at 8 15 eastern
uh no promises i'm i've had a very long
week
but
what's made this week easier is the
incredible support all week long
particularly today i just want to thank
everybody
uh who contributed today with with subs
and obviously the sub bombs were amazing
we're back over 5000 subs i'm super
pumped about that
uh so thank you guys uh this is amazing
stuff hope you enjoyed the speed run
thank you for hanging out
um
thank you for hanging out
i yeah no i know you do and i
appreciate you in return
thank you for hanging out guys take care
enjoy ludwig's return to chess i'll see
you guys later today
later
[Music]
you